je suis tout à fait d'accord pour
l'interdiction aux voitures dans la rue
de l'argenterie
voilà c'était il ya près de 50 ans un
coup de gueule au coeur de montpellier
mais qui résonnait alors de ville en
ville ce même ras-le-bol des voitures du
bruit d'une occupation sans partage de
l'espace public c'est à cette époque au
début des années 70 qu'une demande se
fait de plus en plus pressante
l'aménagement de rues piétonnes
s'appelle en voiture c'est pas c'est pas
une solution
on va beaucoup plus vite à pied rouge
fut la pionnière en france avec la rue
du gros-horloge interdite à la
circulation dès le milieu des années 60
pour le plus grand plaisir de nombreux
piétons
ça permet aux piétons de vos amis chaque
année on va faire les achats puis
traversera chinois est ce que vous êtes
automobilistes n'ont quand même pas ri
suivra avec la piétonnisation de 13 rue
et en 72 c'est tout un secteur de la
capitale qui se ferme à la circulation
l'îlot saint séverin près du quartier de
notre dame
mais ce réaménagement des villes
rencontre aussi des résistances de la
part des commerçants qui craignaient de
voir disparaître leur clientèle si on
transforme cette rue en authentique rue
pieds tant en supprimant les trottoirs
aux cerises
une situation qui conduisait à des
conflits comme dans le quartier de saint
andré des arts en 74 sachet noir et
acquéreur de l'hôtel
il rentrera moi je vais au commissariat
vous venez avec moi j'en ai marre de
tout votre corps inona no no no no on
n'était pas passé la barrière
le mouvement est devenu irréversible
même le président de la république
georges pompidou
pourtant favorable à la voiture réclamer
un meilleur équilibre de même qu'ils
allaient voir en quelque sorte réservés
il y doit y avoir réservé aux piétons et
je regrette pour ma part très vivement
qu'on aille pape
8 la france effectivement est en retard
des grandes villes étrangères avait déjà
pris depuis des années plus tôt comme à
munich où au milieu de la zone piétonne
chacun pouvait exprimer son point de vue
sur la voiture moyennant quelques
marques qui iront à une oeuvre de
bienfaisance
on peut enfin se défouler se venge en
france les centres ville se transforme
petit à petit des rues sont fermées
définitivement à la circulation
quand d'autres le sont seulement
quelques jours dans l'année
ainsi avec l'opération paris respire des
quartiers entiers de la capitale sont
rendues aux piétons une revanche sur les
années 50 quand on se demandait si le
piéton n'était pas une espèce en voie de
disparition
un conseiller municipal vient de poser
la question où passeront il est bientôt
même passeront-ils verrons-nous après la
fin des trottoirs la fin des piétons
[Musique]